ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lecture for today I've
entitled 'Logarithms Without
Exponents'.
And before I try to clarify
that, let me make a couple of
general remarks.
First of all, we have now
completed the rudiments, the
basics so to speak, of
both differential
and integral calculus.
Consequently, what our next
ambition will be is to take
these principles and apply
them to special functions
which are worthy of
investigation.
And you see, in connection with
this, the first function
that I've chosen to talk about
is called the logarithm.
Now the other interesting thing
is that we are used to
logarithms from high school
where they were viewed as
being a different kind
of notation for
talking about exponents.
Now, in the same way when
we treated the circular
functions, we mentioned that
one did not have to invent
triangles to talk about
trigonometry.
The interesting point is that
one does not have to talk
about exponents to invent
the logarithm function.
This is why I have entitled
the lesson, as I say,
'Logarithms without
Exponents'.
You see, what I would like to do
is try to mimic, especially
from an engineering point of
view, how many of these
mathematical topics
originated.
Let's look at a rather
straightforward physical
principle, a principle that I'm
sure we believe permeates
many real life situations.
It's what I call the rule
of compound interest.
Namely, let's suppose we have a
physical situation in which
the quantity that
we're measuring,
which we'll call 'm'.
In other words, the rate of
change of the quantity is
proportional to the amount
present, 'dm/ dt' equals 'km'.
Now notice that this is a pretty
harmless statement.
The rate of change
is proportional
to the amount present.
We certainly would expect that
many experiments would run
this way, and there seems to be
nothing at all supernatural
about this kind of
an assumption.
At any rate, let's apply our
previous principles, and see
if we can't, from this
differential equation, figure
out what 'm' has to be.
Separating the variables, we
get that 'dm' over 'm' is
equal to 'kdt'.
And now integrating, meaning
taking the inverse derivative,
we have what?
That the integral of 'dm'
over 'm' is equal
to 'kt' plus a constant.
Now you see, the interesting
point is at this stage of the
game, we do not know explicitly
how to find a
function whose derivative with
respect to 'm' is '1 over m'.
In fact, that's the
problem that
underlies today's lecture.
And we will try to answer this
question, showing how once we
tackle this from a philosophic
point of view, the rest of the
details follow from material
that we've already learned.
At any rate, focusing our
attention on the problem, the
question is this: to determine
a function, which I'll call
capital 'L of x'--
the 'L' sort of to forewarn us
of the fact that we will
somehow get a logarithm
out of this--
such that 'L prime of
x' is '1 over x'.
And you see, what I want you to
notice is that if you write
'1 over x' in exponential form,
in other words, if you
try to write '1 over x' as 'x
to the n', notice that to
solve this problem, 'L
of x' would be what?
The integral of 'x' to
the 'minus 1 dx'.
In other words, this is the case
of integral ''x to the n'
dx', with 'n' equal
to minus 1.
And you'll recall that when
we studied the recipe--
let me just write that over
here-- when we studied the
recipe of how you integrate 'x
to the n', we saw that that
was 'x to the 'n + 1'' over
'n + 1' plus a constant.
And we then observed that this
doesn't even make sense when
'n' is equal to minus 1,
because we have a 0
denominator.
From the other point of view,
the way to look at
this is we said what?
That when you differentiate, you
lower the exponent by 1.
Notice that to wind up with an
exponent of minus 1, we would
have had to start with
an exponent of 0.
But when you differentiate 'x'
to the 0, that being a
constant, the derivative
of 'x' to the 0 is 0.
It's not '1 over x'.
You see, in other words, this
particular recipe that we're
talking about, we don't
have working for us.
In other words, this is an
interesting point again.
You say gee whiz, if the recipe
for the integral ''x to
the n' dx' works for everything
except 'n' equals
minus 1, nothing's perfect.
Let's be content.
Since it works for every
number except
that one, why worry?
This is analogous to when
we talked about taking
derivatives and saw that
we get a 0 over
0 form every time.
You see, if you pick a function
at random, the
likelihood that the limit of
'f of x' as 'x' approaches
'a', the likelihood of that
being 0 over 0 is very small,
except when you form
the derivative, you
always get 0 over 0.
And in a similar way, granted
that integral ''x' to the
minus 1 dx' is one very
special case.
What we have seen is that this
comes up every single time
that we want to solve a problem
of the form 'dm/ dt'
equals 'km'.
In other words then, what it
really boils down to is that
unless we can come up with
a function 'L of x' whose
derivative is '1 over x', we
cannot solve the problem that
we started off today's
lesson with.
In other words, we must leave
it in the form integral 'dm
over m' equals 'kt'
plus a constant.
Well at any rate, let's see what
such a function capital
'L of x' must look like.
I'm going to utilize both the
differential calculus approach
and the integral calculus
approach.
By differential calculus,
assuming that 'y' equals 'L of
x', what do we know about
the function 'y'?
By definition, we've defined it
to be that function whose
derivative is '1 over x'.
So we know its derivative
is '1 over x'.
The next point is that knowing
that 'y prime' is '1 over x',
and even though we can't
integrate '1 over x', we can
certainly differentiate
'1 over x'.
We can now differentiate
The derivative of '1 over x' is
minus '1 over 'x squared'',
and we find that 'y
double prime' is
minus '1 over 'x squared''.
By the way, we should observe
that we must shy away from 'x'
equaling 0, because you see, we
would have a 0 denominator
in that case.
If we think of most physical
situations, notice that we
talk about the amount--
the rate of change
is proportional
to the amount present.
From a physical point of view,
the amount present can't be
negative, so let's put the
restriction on here that the
domain of 'L' will be all
positive numbers.
Now here's the interesting
thing.
Intuitively, I can now visualize
how the function 'L
of x' must look.
Namely, since its first
derivative is '1 over x' and
'x' is greater than 0, that
tells me that the curve is
always rising.
And secondly, since '1 over 'x
squared'' is always positive,
minus '1 over 'x squared'' is
always negative, that tells me
that my curve is always
spilling water.
In essence then, what
must the curve do?
The curve must be rising
but spilling water.
In other words, the curve
'L of x' belongs to this
particular family.
Notice that once we have one
curve which we call 'y' equals
'L of x', by any displacement
parallel--
vertical displacement,
we get what?
A member called 'y' equals
'L of x' plus 'c'.
All that changes is what?
The point at which the curve
crosses the x-axis, but
whichever member of the
family we pick, what
typifies 'L of x'?
Its derivative is '1 over x'.
In other words, somehow or
other, we visualize that 'L of
x' exists, and its graph
is something like this.
Now suppose we want a more
tangible form, namely how do
you compute 'L of x'
for a given 'x'?
I thought what might be a nice
review now is to see how we
can use our integral calculus
approach, and in particular
the second fundamental theorem
of interval calculus.
By the integral calculus
approach, we do is is we pick
any positive number 'a', and
once picked, we fix it.
You see, we have a great deal
of freedom in how we choose
the positive number a.
But let's pick one and
leave it here.
Now what we'll do is in the
'y-t' plane, we'll draw the
curve 'y' equals '1 over t'.
And what we'll do now, we'll
study the area of the region
'R' where 'R' is bounded above
by 'y' equals '1 over t', on
the left by 't' equals 'a', on
the right by 't' equals 'x',
and below by the t-axis.
Now we've already seen that the
function that we get by
taking the definite integral
from 'a' 'to x', 'dt over t',
has the property that its
derivative is '1 over x'.
In other words, recall from the
fundamental theorem, this
is just a generalization of the
fact that if 'f of t' is a
continuous function, then the
integral from 'a' to 'x', ''f
of t' dt', is a function
of 'x'.
And its derivative with
respect to 'x'
is just 'f of x'.
You see, in other words, I can
now view capital 'L of x' as
being an area under the curve
'y' equals '1 over t'.
Notice that I have a degree of
freedom here, namely what that
area is depends on where
I choose 'a'.
Notice that if I choose a
differently, changing 'a'--
let's call this 'a
prime', say--
changing 'a' changes the area
under the curve, but notice it
changes it by a fixed amount.
In other words, notice that
shifting 'a' just changes 'L
of x' by a constant,
just like the
ordinary in definite integral.
At any rate, these are the two
approaches that we have.
And if we superimpose them,
all we're saying is what?
If you start with the
differential calculus
approach, 'y' equals capital 'L
of x' must be a member of
this family, crossing the axis
at some point (a,0) .
And from the integral calculus
point of view, if you take the
curve 'y' equals '1 over t'
and compute the area under
that curve from 'a'
to 'x', that area
function is 'L of x'.
Now we'll let that rest for the
time being, and now have a
brief digression.
You see, sooner or later, I've
got to get to what a logarithm
is, and we might just
as well do that now.
So let's now take a look and
see what we mean by a
logarithmic function.
You see, quite frequently in
mathematics, what one does is
one deals with a particular
special case in which one is
interested.
And having deduced very nice
results, he looks at this
thing and says, you know, all
of these results came from a
particular recipe, a particular
structure that this
system obeyed.
What he then does is he takes
this recipe or structure,
gives it a general name, and
now is able to extend this
property to a larger
class of objects.
For example, let's
look at this way.
What is the nice thing about
logarithms in the traditional
sense of the word?
Remember when we learned
logarithms in high school, by
use of logarithms, we were able
to replace multiplication
problems by addition problems,
et cetera.
In other words, remember the
key structural property was
that the logarithm of a product
was the sum of the
logarithms.
That was the structural thing
that we used over and over and
over again.
In fact, it's rather interesting
to point out that
in many cases where we used the
properties of logarithms,
we never really had to know
what a logarithm was.
All we had to know was what?
What properties did it obey,
and did we have a book of
tables so we could look up the
logarithm when we had to.
Well at any rate, using this as
motivation, we now define a
logarithmic function,
specifically a function f is
called logarithmic if for all
'x1', 'x2' in the domain of
'f', 'f' of the product of 'x1'
and 'x2' is 'f of x1'
plus 'f of x2'.
In other words, since we know
what nice properties a
logarithm has, let's define
any function 'f' to be
logarithmic if 'f' of a
product is equal to
the sum of the 'f's.
Now you see, this may sound
like a pretty simple
statement, but it's
quite demanding.
In other words, notice--
by the way, somebody says,
I wonder if there are any
logarithmic functions?
You see, notice that by the way
we began, there must be at
least one logarithmic function,
namely the usual logarithm.
We know there's at least one
function which has these
properties.
So the set of all logarithmic
functions is certainly
not the empty set.
At any rate, let's see what
we can deduce about any
logarithmic function.
Well for example, I claim that
if 'f' is logarithmic, 'f of
1' must be 0.
Why is that?
Well, notice that 1 can be
written as 1 times 1.
And since 'f of 1' times
1 is 'f of 1' plus 'f
of 1', we have what?
That 'f of 1' is equal to 'f of
1' plus 'f of 1', therefore
twice 'f of 1' is 'f of 1',
and therefore by algebraic
manipulation, 'f of 1' is 0.
Which, by the way, does check
out with the usual logarithm,
the logarithm of 1 to
any base 'b' is 0.
Secondly, if 'f of '1 over x''
is defined, you see in other
words, I'm not sure whether '1
over x' is in the domain of
'f' just because 'x' is, but
suppose '1 over x' is in the
domain of 'f'.
Then 'f of '1 over x'' is
equal to minus 'f of x'.
In other words, 'f' of a number
is minus 'f' of the
reciprocal of that number.
Again, a familiar logarithmic
property, why does it follow
from our basic definition?
Well notice that we already
know that 'f of 1' is 0.
We also know that 1 is equal
to 'x' times '1 over x',
provided 'x' is not 0.
By the way, if 'x' were 0, 1
over 0 wouldn't be defined, so
we wouldn't be worrying
about that anyway.
But notice now we have what?
If 'x' is not 0, 'f of 'x times
'1 over x'' is 0, but by
the logarithmic property, that's
also 'f of x' plus 'f
of '1 over x''.
Since these two together add up
to 0, 'f of '1 over x' must
just be minus 'f of x'.
And we'll just take a few more
properties like this just to
make sure that you see what
properties logarithmic
functions have.
Remember again the ordinary
logarithm, the logarithm of a
quotient was the difference
of the logarithms.
Again, 'f of 'x over y''
is equal to 'f of
x' minus 'f of y'.
Why is that the case?
Well, look at 'f
of 'x over y''.
That says 'f of x'
times '1 over y'.
But again, by logarithmic
properties, 'f' of a product
is the sum of the 'f's.
Therefore 'f of 'x times '1 over
y''' is 'f of x' plus 'f
of '1 over y''.
But we just saw that 'f of '1
over y' is minus 'f of y'.
So we have this familiar
result now.
And finally, by mathematical
induction, if 'n' is any
positive integer, 'f of x' to
the n-th power is just 'n'
times 'f of x'.
And the proof is rather clear.
Namely, 'f of x' to the n-th
power when 'n' is a positive
integer means 'f of 'x'
times 'x' times 'x'
times 'x'', 'n' times.
And since the logarithmic
property says that 'f' of a
product is a sum of the 'f's,
that's equal to 'f of x' plus
'f of x' plus et cetera plus 'f
of x', 'n' times, and that
precisely is just 'n'
times 'f of x'.
In other words, notice that
our definition of a
logarithmic function, simply
that 'f of 'x1 times x2'' is
equal to 'f of x1' plus 'f of
x2' allows us to deduce all of
the familiar properties that
were known to us in terms of
the traditional meaning
of logarithm.
And now we come to the most
important question of today's
lecture, and that is what does
all of this discussion have to
do with the function that we've
called capital 'L of x'?
And that's what will
tackle next.
Let's take a look and see
whether capital 'L of x' is
indeed a logarithmic function.
Well, if 'L' is to be a
logarithmic function, if 'b'
is any constant, in particular
'L of 'b times x'' had better
be equal to 'L of b'
plus 'L of x'.
That's the definition
of logarithmic.
Now we don't know
if that's true.
What do we have at our disposal
to be able to see
whether we can solve this
problem or not?
How do we, using calculus,
check to see whether two
functions are equal?
Remember the standard
approach is what?
Take the derivative
of both sides.
If the derivatives are
equal, then the
functions differ by a constant.
And if we can show that that
constant is 0, then the two
functions are equal.
So let's take a look and see
how that works over here.
First of all, let's see what the
derivative of 'L of bx' is
with respect to 'x'.
And by the way, here again is
the beauty of what we mean
when we say that all of the
study that we're making allows
us to utilize every fundamental
result that we've
learned before.
We've learned that the basic
definition of 'L' is what?
That if you differentiate 'L'
with respect to the given
variable, you get 1 over
that variable.
We want the derivative of 'L
of bx' with respect to 'x'.
Now, you see the idea is the
derivative of 'L of u' with
respect to 'u' is '1 over u'.
You see by the chain rule, if we
were differentiating 'L of
bx' with respect to 'bx', that
would be '1 over bx'.
I shouldn't say by the
chain rule yet.
What I'm saying is if we
differentiate 'L of bx' with
respect to 'bx', we would
have '1 over bx'.
But we're not differentiating
with respect to 'bx', we're
differentiating with
respect to 'x'.
And this is where the
chain rule comes in.
Namely, we rewrite the
derivative of 'L of bx' with
respect to 'x' as the derivative
'L of bx' with
respect to 'bx' times the
derivative of 'bx' with
respect to 'b'.
And in this way we get what?
The first factor
is '1 over bx'.
The second factor
is 'b' itself--
remember 'b' is a constant--
and therefore the derivative
of 'L of bx' is '1 over x'.
On the other hand, what is
the derivative of 'L of
b' plus 'L of x'?
Since 'b' is a constant, the
derivative 'L of b' is 0.
And by definition, the
derivative of 'L of x' with
respect to 'x' is '1 over x'.
And now you see, comparing these
two results, we see that
'L of bx' and 'L of b' plus 'L
of x have the same derivative,
hence they differ by a constant
which I'll call 'c'.
In other words, notice that
capital 'L' is what I call
almost logarithmic.
If it weren't for this factor
constant 'c' in here, it would
be a logarithmic function.
Well at any rate,
what do we have?
We know that capital 'L of bx'
is equal to capital 'L of b'
plus capital 'L of x' plus
some constant 'c'.
To evaluate the constant, we
only have to evaluate it at
one element in the domain, let's
pick 'x' equal to 1.
The motif being that if 'x' is
1, notice that on the left
hand side you have an 'L of b'
term, on the right hand side
you have an 'L of b' term,
and they will cancel.
In other words, if 'x' is 1,
this equation becomes 'L of b'
equals 'L of b' plus 'L of 1'
plus 'c', from which it
follows that 'c' is
minus 'L of 1'.
'c' is minus 'L of 1'.
Now what do we want to 'c' to
be if 'c' were equal to 0?
If 'c' where equal to 0, this
would be logarithmic, and all
we need to make 'c' equal to 0
is to set 'L of 1' equal to 0.
In other words, summarizing this
result, capital 'L of x'
is logarithmic if capital
'L of 1' is 0.
Now remember, we have a whole
family of 'L's that work.
What we're saying now is let's
pick the member of the family
of 'L's that passes through
the point (1,0) .
And because that's logarithmic,
let's give that a
special name.
In essence, we will define
this symbol.
It's written 'ln of x'.
It will later be called the
natural logarithm of 'x'.
I'm trying to avoid the word
logarithm here as much as
possible, because I want you to
see that we haven't had to
use exponents at all in making
this kind of a definition.
But let's define 'ln of x' to
be the member of the family
capital 'L of x' plus
'c' which passes
through the point (1,0).
In essence then, what
is 'ln of x'?
I'll call it natural log, it's
easier for me to say.
The natural 'log of x' is that
function whose derivative with
respect to 'x' is '1 over
x', and characterized by
the fact that what?
If the input is 1,
the output is 0.
In other words, the graph
passes through
the point (1 , 0).
Again, notice that in terms
of what we said earlier in
today's lesson, we talked about
the functions 'L of x',
and talked about, in the
differential calculus
approach, the curve could
go through any
point on the x-axis.
What we're saying is now if the
point on the x-axis that
the curve crosses at is (1 ,
0), that's what 'lnx' will
mean, the natural
log function.
In terms of the integral
calculus approach, if the
particular 'a' value that we
choose, the fixed value that
we're going to study the area
under, notice that all we're
saying is pick 'a' to be 1.
And by the way, as a
quick check, all
we're saying is what?
The 'natural log of x' is
defined to be the area under
this curve as a function
of 'x'.
In terms of the definite
integral, that's the integral
from '1 to x,' 'dt over t'.
And notice that if you pick 'x'
to be 1, the natural log
of 1 is the integral from 1 to
1 'dt over t', and that's 0,
just as it should be.
So at any rate now, that
tells me how to
define the natural log.
Am I doing this in terms
of exponents?
No.
I am trying to do what?
Find a function whose derivative
with respect to 'x'
is '1 over x', and I'd also like
that function, since it's
that close to being a
logarithmic function, to be a
logarithmic function.
In other words, this is how I
invented the function 'ln of
x', the 'natural log of x'.
It's derivative with respect to
'x' is '1 over x', and the
natural log of a product is the
sum of the natural logs.
And by the way, that's exactly
how we use this material.
Let me just take a few minutes
and go over something that we
already had an answer
for, just to show
you how this works.
Let me try to rederive the
product rule using logarithms.
Suppose 'u' and 'v' are
differentiable functions of
'x', and I want to find the
derivative of 'u' times 'v'
with respect to 'x'.
In other words, I'd like
to find 'dy dx'.
OK, I take the natural
log of both sides.
In other words, I say if 'y'
equals 'u' times 'v', the
natural log 'y' equals natural
log 'u times v'.
Now what is the property that
the natural log function has?
I deliberately chose it to be
that member of the l family
that was logarithmic.
The natural log of 'u times
v' is 'natural log u' plus
'natural log v'.
Now, can I differentiate
this implicitly
with respect to 'x'?
You see how all of our
old stuff keeps
coming up in new context.
I take this equation and I
differentiate it implicitly
with respect to 'x'.
The derivative of the
left hand side is '1
over y', 'dy dx'.
The derivative of the right
hand side is what?
Well, the derivative of 'log u'
with respect to 'u' is '1
over u', but I'm differentiating
it with
respect to 'x', so I must use
the correction factor by the
chain rule 'du dx'.
And similarly, the derivative of
'log v' with respect to 'x'
is '1 over v', 'dv dx'.
And now multiplying through by
'y', I have obtained that 'dy
dx' is ''y over u' du dx'
plus ''y over v' dv dx'.
But remembering that 'y' is
equal to 'u' times 'v', this
becomes 'v 'du dx'' plus 'u 'dv
dx', and we have arrived
at the familiar product
rule using logarithmic
differentiation.
You see the point that's really
important to stress
here it that it wasn't important
whether the natural
log was an exponent or not.
The important thing that we used
about logarithms, whether
it was our high school course,
whether it's going to be in
our college calculus course, the
important thing was what?
That when we wanted to write the
log of a product, it was
the sum of the logs.
And now the only additional
fact that we have from the
calculus approach is that the
derivative of 'log x' with
respect to 'x' was defined
to be '1 over x'.
By the way, since there is
a tendency to think of
traditional logarithms when one
uses the word logarithm,
if we so wanted--
and there's no reason why
we have to do this--
if we wanted to associate
a base with
the natural log system--
this is just a little aside, and
we'll talk about this more
perhaps in the learning
exercises or in the
supplementary notes
as need be--
but the idea is this.
Notice that in a traditional
logarithm system, if the base
is 'b', the base is
characterized by the fact that
the 'log of 'b to the
base b'' is 1.
Thus, if we use 'e' to denote
the base for the natural log,
whatever 'e' is, it must be
characterized by the fact that
the 'natural log of e' is 1.
And the reason that I put the
word base in quotation marks
here is that I would like you
to observe that again, if I
have never heard of the word
exponent, it still makes sense
to say find the number e
such that the 'natural
log of e' is 1.
In fact, I can give you two
interpretations for that
number 'e', and as a byproduct,
even show you why
the second fundamental theorem
of integral calculus is as
powerful as it really is.
See, the idea is this.
To find what 'e' is, all we're
saying is take the curve 'y'
equals 'natural log x'.
Look to see where the
y-coordinate is 1.
In other words, draw the
line 'y' equals 1.
Where that line intercepts the
curve 'y' equals 'log x', that
x-coordinate is 'e'.
In other words, the 'natural log
of e' must be 1, so this
is geometrically how I would
locate 'e' using
differential calculus.
If I wanted to use integral
calculus, notice that the 'log
of e' by definition is what?
The integral from 1 to
'e', 'dt over t'.
That's the area of
this region 'R'.
Now what do I want 'e' to be?
I want 'e' to be that number
that makes this area 1.
In other words, I want the
'natural log of e' to be 1.
So again, in the same way that
one can think of pi as being
geometrically constructed,
notice I can construct 'e'
geometrically, namely
again what?
I take the curve 'y' equals '1
over t' from 't' equals 1,
bounded below by the t-axis,
and I keep shifting over to
the right until the area of this
region 'R' is exactly 1.
The 't' value that makes this
area 1 is called 'e'.
And by the way, notice again
the power of what I mean by
the area approach.
Notice I can start now to
get estimates on what
'e' must look like.
Let me show you what I'm
driving at over here.
Let's suppose we take the curve
'y' equals '1 over t'
from 1 to 2.
Now what do we mean
by natural log 2?
Natural log 2 is by definition
the area of this region here.
Now notice that the smallest
height of this region, since
the curve is 'y' equals '1 over
t', the smallest height
of this region is 1/2, and the
tallest height, the highest
height in this region is 1.
Consequently, whatever the area
of this region is, it's
less than the area of the
inscribed rectangle--
it's greater than the area of
the inscribed rectangle, and
less than the area of the
circumscribed rectangle.
Now notice that both of these
rectangles have base 1, and
we're going from 1 to 2.
The height of the inscribed
rectangle is 1/2, therefore
the area of the small
rectangle is 1/2.
The area of the big rectangle,
it's a 1 by 1 rectangle, is 1.
And now what we have is that
whatever the natural log of 2
is, it being the area of this
region, it must be what?
Less than 1 but greater
than 1/2.
We also know that whatever
'e' is, the 'log of
e' is equal to 1.
Well, let's go on a little
bit further.
What about the log of 4?
The log of 4, natural log of
4, is the log of 2 squared.
But we've already seen that
one of the properties of a
logarithmic function is that
you can bring the exponent
down as a multiplier.
See, 'f of 'x to the n''
is 'n 'f of x''.
This becomes 2 log 2, and
because the natural log of 2
is greater than 1/2, twice
the natural log of 2
is more than 1.
In other words, if log 2 is more
than 1/2, twice log 2 is
more than 1.
In other words, if we put these
three lines together, we
have that the natural log of 2
is less than the 'natural log
of e', which in turn is less
than the natural log of 4.
By the way, notice that since
the derivative of 'log x' with
respect to 'x' is '1 over x',
and that's positive, 'log x'
is a one to one function.
Therefore, if the log of 2 is
less than the 'log of e' is
less than the log of 4, it
follows that 2 must be less
than 'e', which in turn
must be less than 4.
In other words, even with this
crude approximation of just
inscribing and circumscribing
rectangles, I can show again
without reference to exponents
that whatever the number 'e'
is, the number e defined by the
fact that 'ln of e' is 1,
that number 'e' is some number
between 2 and 4.
But again, we won't dwell
on this too long.
What I want to do now is to come
back to a summary point,
and at the same time,
lead into the
lecture for next time.
Recall that we began this
lecture with the problem of
solving the situation where
the rate of change was
proportional to the
amount present.
Given 'dm/ dt' equals 'km', we
separated variables and got
down to the stage where the
integral of 'dm over m' was
'kt' plus a constant.
And all we did in the rest of
today's lecture that was at
all different, was we invented
and constructed the particular
function whose derivative would
be '1 over m', and which
had the logarithmic property.
In other words, we can now
say that this is the
answer to the problem.
This problem is explicitly
solved because the natural log
function can be viewed as
an area under a curve.
We can construct it
for each 'm'.
This is then what we
managed to do.
And by the way, all I'm saying
now is that since the log is a
one to one function--
see, its derivative is
always positive--
can't we talk about the
inverse function?
In other words, notice that
another way of writing this is
that id 'natural log m' is 'kt'
plus 'c', 'm' itself must
be the 'inverse log
of kt' plus 'c'.
And you see, next time what
we're going to do is to
explore what we mean
by the inverse log.
At any rate, in summarizing
today's lecture, to make sure
that we didn't fall victim to
all the computational details,
notice that all we did was
physically motivated the
necessity for inventing a
function whose derivative with
respect to 'x' was '1 over x'.
And from that point on,
everything else that we did
followed as applications of
material that came before.
It's in this sense that the
course now picks up in tempo.
That as we go on now, we're
going to be able to cover
larger globs of material in one
sitting, because we will
find, at least for the next
several lectures, that every
new topic is basically one new
idea together with all of the
old recipes.
At any rate, until next
time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.